probably gonna be talking for a little
bit y'all so bear with me because
obviously there's a ton you know stuff
to discuss here Microsoft versus FTC
round two we try to avoid most of it but
look we have to talk about is one of the
hottest things the trial of the century
so to speak and a lot of key points so
look I'm not going to talk about
everything but I have to focus on a
couple of key points that happen this
week so excuse me for my rambling all
right Bobby kotec takes the stand he has
some things to say um doesn't want to
make Call of Duty exclusive when asked
if he ever thought about making Cod
exclusive to what platform he said no
you would alienate over 100 million
monthly active players half of them play
on phones but the rest of them play on
computer and PlayStation and you would
have a Revolt if you to remove the game
from more than one platform Bobby also
said that it would be very detrimental
to our business to take Call of Duty off
PlayStation he also talked about the
Nintendo switch he didn't think it was
at first was going to be popular he also
admitted he was wrong given that switch
has now sold well over 1 100 million
units Bobby said it was a mistake not to
put Call of Duty on the current switch
and he briefly spoke about how
Activision will approach future Nintendo
consoles based on these uh comments it
seems that you know Call of Duty will
come to Nintendo consoles once he gets
detailed specifications but then he
low-key reveal Nintendo's consoles
performance and power the new one will
be similar to that of the PS4 and Xbox
One so Bobby Loki let that one out he
also said Bobby Bobby is going to be the
most election it's enough to run Cod at
60.
clearly yeah that's what it is he also
said uh Bobby said PlayStation will be
fine if the active acquisition goes
through he said that Sony has an
enormous competitive advantage in its
ability to develop new IP and he decided
the last of us as an example of taking a
video game IP and turning it into a
successful multimedia franchise he
expressed confidence if the deal goes
through that Sony would remain
competitive saying Sony has the best
game developer purpose in the world Sony
is the most successful Bobby he was the
most successful consumer electronics
company of all time
Bobby said they have distribution
[Laughter]
Bobby said they have distribution in
every country every small town
everywhere in the world
what's that BDC even take a small town
and tie it down that's what he at like
Bobby was on the stand like he also said
degrading a PlayStation version of Call
of Duty doesn't make sense he argued
that the um Microsoft he said that um
they wouldn't do that saying the vitriol
would follow from Gamers and ensuing
damage to the company would be well
deserved he said that developers take
pride in their work and want to make
good games he's never heard of
developers making a subpar game for one
platform compared to another and this
was also reiterated by good friend to
the realm Lord Patrick rennet respawn
who didn't mince his words on Twitter he
said No Game Dev willingly tries to put
out an inferior release with less
quality and more bugs no one would do
that we want to make things that people
enjoy and will always try to ship the
best product despite any circumstances
for Jim Ryan to suggest otherwise is
asinine these are his words I'm just
repeating what he's in all right and
then the other details that came out
after Bobby's you know took the stand he
saw him there's pretty much you know as
far as such there was a Sharpie that was
yeah real quick yes you know how they
say when you always accusing the other
people of something you probably doing
it yourself
Jim Ryan's like oh God we we do that
they might do that now
some other details was revealed in the
case someone with a with bad Sharpie
skills got in trouble because they
unsuccessfully attempted to redact
information on Sony and Microsoft
documents thanks to this we now know
that Horizon forbidden West and The Last
of Us part 2 cost more than 200 million
to make uh shout out to games
industry.biz this revolution explored
the economics exclusivity where Sony has
certain advantages that enable it to
spend much more money on its AAA
offerings whereas most Publishers need
to rely on post launch purchases such as
season passes and micro tracks
transactions to recoup costs exclusivity
deals offer an alternative so by
becoming a PlayStation exclusive games
like Final Fantasy 16 more or less end
up having the economic advantage of a
first party title Sony has most likely
waived most if not all of its platform
fee for the game and almost almost
certainly absolved some of the marketing
costs so that came out and now we're
here for the main event because I see my
man ever Bill sponsored and pulled out
might check real quick search want to
make sure I hear you crispy yeah there
we go there we go no down real smooth so
for the main event shout out to VGC
Microsoft explored the possibility of
acquiring Sega Bungie and IO interactive
in recent years in November 2020 Phil
Spencer emailed CEO Satya Nadella And
the Company CFO Amy Hood requesting
approval to approach Sega Sammy with a
view to acquiring its game studios we
believe this is Phil's comments that
Sega has built a well-balanced portfolio
of games across segments with global
graphical appeal and will help us
accelerate Xbox game pass both on and
off console Phil added Sega is the most
attractive next acquisition Target due
to its Global PC catalog presence on
mobile and Asia and Global brand
Affinity on Console through its classic
IP I like classic IP solve I like that I
like that I love that too well it's
unclear how Nadella responded to
Spencer's request Sega was also listed
on the mergers and acquisition's final
watch list this document was from April
2021. Bungie which was also laid
acquired by Sony and Zynga which would
go on to merge with uh Rockstar take two
was also both of those were also on this
mergers and Acquisitions list so look a
lot to unpack here you know a lot of
standouts a lot of talk you know let's
start with uh ksrt first man K you know
obviously it was a lot to unpack here
and then obviously the uh the Sega
Bungie you know in news as well so just
any thoughts of stuff that happened this
week and then obviously the Sega and
Bungie I I will talk
in general uh it's been an interesting
week right uh uh I I think we've learned
more uh I think somebody on my show said
that that uh that uh uh ABK versus
versus the FTC is itself an RPG and
we're the ones that are gaining all the
experience points yeah you know we we're
all galvanized at this process and you
know we're trading we're trading stories
and And discussing what some of these
things mean uh you know at the end of it
all I if we ever go through it again I
think you know if nothing else we we as
a community have learned a lot in in
this short amount of time with all the
all the the legalese that have been
thrown at us and things like that so I I
just found that super interesting I mean
I'm over here you know I work a
corporate job I I I will say I am
somewhat in an upper echelon in this
corporate job so I have people that rely
on me and instead I'm here fooling
around with speakers blaring because
we're trying to hear this thing and Mr
Mr ever born soccer couldn't get in so
now I'm blaring the speakers he's on
speakerphone just so he can hear what
we're doing we did this all day
you know it was it was just that kind of
a feeling you know so so for me it was
just super super entertaining and super
interesting and the the uh I've always
been kind of into the the minutia of of
processes so this is awesome I'm a guy
I'm one of those people that that
watches like like legal dramas you know
so this this was great yeah you get all
the dirt you're getting all the details
exactly exactly you know so so in
general at a high level I thought that
you know
it was a very interesting process I
appreciated the fact that they let the
the public at least listen I wish we had
been able to see you know every once in
a while they kind of let it slip and a
video would come out and be like this
small and then they'd take it away you
know for those of us that got into the
stream you know but no by and large you
know the uh um um it's no it's no
mistake to uh um that most people who
have been paying attention say that the
government has no case and because of
that they've been kind of trying to find
other ways around to thread the needle I
personally don't think they did that
with here but it was very interesting to
me to see all the various ways they
tried that you know tried to discredit
that right you know things things like
you know they'll they'll they'll use
they'll sit sit on the fact that there
is a there is a marketing uh contract
with PlayStation until 2025 so that's
good but the minute that Microsoft talks
about their contracts no no don't
believe them that's the contract this
fine print you don't see it it's really
fine but no they're Liars who lie don't
don't listen to them it was very it was
very you know the way they kept
threading that was stupid
you know they'd be on the stand and
literally under oath say the the most
black and white thing and then you the
the lawyer would then spend the next one
you know 20 minutes poking as many holes
as he can and some of it was like kind
of naked on its face to the point where
even the judge had to be like come on
bro move on yeah yeah just curly was
outside with moving things along yeah
that's right you know the the wrap it up
B music started playing you know
definitely some wrapping up the energy
let's say it takes the show yes yes you
know yes yeah
you know so no but I high level I really
do think it was super entertaining it
was super interesting for us the
community to be a part of it you know uh
I I think we being as galvanized as we
were was necessary because it kind of
gave a little bit of pressure to all
sides of the official proceedings
because even though they won't listen to
the console Warriors and the and the
Fanboys in the crowd they do still see
that man our 1000 limit stream gets
locked yes
every moment like there are some people
who waited the day before you know what
I mean
just just really quick now you said they
don't listen to us but I spent five days
listening to the FTC using Pony sure
sure yes sir yes sir yes sir I stand
corrected yes absolutely they don't
listen to it absolutely well I I'm I'm
I'm presuming that you know while
they're going through the business of
doing of doing you know proper work
they're not listening to the kids in in
the hall yelling about it but I do take
your point that they probably listened a
little too much than they should because
some of those talking points a little
bit you know most like craziest Fanboys
on Twitter that's their brother or
sister man this is what you guys say
this is what's going down
you know yeah it is interesting
[Laughter]
protecting the branch that's what she
kept going on you don't think that would
making a difference yeah she was she has
very pointed comments I noticed uh in
reference to trying to understand you
have to see lawyer arguments and things
of that nature but uh what I think
before I pass it off from you um ksrt so
like in general like the other because
again focusing on the Sega and the
bungee part you know like now that you
see this information you know and it's
more it's huge M A you know watchless
like what was your thoughts when you saw
did you see the full one where they had
like the verbiage that said this is the
pros this is the recommendation yeah
like like was your thoughts on that so
so I have to I have to be I have to be
absolutely honest and I'm here I'm here
in the realm with all my family and all
the all the Gaming Community my first
thought was oh damn I'm never gonna hear
the address
because I'm sitting there and I'm like
bro we authenticated like it's so good
to see but but we're going to go let
everybody get this moment because you
are his co-host and you you know
sometimes you try to keep our brother in
line with his expectations but to read
his words or these words of the paper
validating him so how did it feel so so
to be clear to be clear you know he and
I by and large feel almost identical in
in all all things okay I'm excited for
all this but as is our Dynamic he's the
Ying to my end we keep each other in
line you know you know what I'm saying
so you know seeing this and it was like
as as pong Soul likes to call it the
honey-do list it was just so detailed I
was like oh my goodness it was so down
to the down to the Fanboy levels I was
like these guys spend too much time on
Spaces they were spitting about the
value
absolutely absolutely no but I I will
say like jokes aside yes I appreciate
the fact that what people have been
complaining about from Xbox for a long
time now oh stop the Mia Copa be
aggressive show some teeth they were
doing that they were really we're doing
that yeah like that though not like
that's too much
Sony in the background was doing what
Sony do to you know try the new sniping
absolutely absolutely see I like I I the
the takeaway from all the background
that came out of this was I gotta put
respect on Booty's name man you gotta
put respect on their name you know
and I'm not I'm not gonna go there
because it's PG-13 today I'm not doing
it I usually can't help myself but I'm
gonna fight I'm not gonna do it but no
honestly you know people and that's
that's that's that's the thing we hear a
lot in the community oh show some teeth
be aggressive you know they don't put it
on Front Street but clearly they are
hearing you and they're taking those
actions and I thought that was super
interesting how it goes from here we
shall see yeah but I I the fact that at
least on in the emails and you know and
when they're talking amongst themselves
they are as Cut Throat as some of y'all
want them to be that is refreshing news
the next stuff I gotta talk about
my Sega bro ever born Saga you know us
us is often Sega kids we didn't have a
home you know say at the start of the
whole generation you know what I mean we
were looking for a place to go and it
just felt refugees you know we were left
refugees we just felt like Xbox was the
place to go things seemed a little
familiar right so you know what I mean
you saw you saw some remnants of Sega in
there you saw some titles on the OG X
Box right and you're like okay baby I
could I could you know kind of find
shelter here but we figured what
happened out to our beloved Sega so ever
bought a saga man like when you get a
chance to read these documents you see
Phil's comments you see the aggressive
push and the descriptive nature of why
Sega is value to Xbox and why they
wasn't crying how did it make you feel
brother
he's quiet he's overjoyed
it's Beauty clearly he muted sir he must
be muted he's Beauty he's building it
he's always muted there you go that was
that was Jim Ryan
so how does it feel the thing that I
gotta say let's go is they thought I was
wrong but I knew it all along
now now now check this out all right and
I want to I want first of all happy
birthday to King I already told you in
Italian
now I want to give a shout out to King
David because he gave Phil the first
name which is Phil Dominus Maximus a
really expensive but but King also has
introduced a new form to fulfilled with
this Darth fill
Darth Phil the Destroyer
oh my God and so uh and I want I want to
point this out and this part is a little
bit for you sobs you know
Bill heard that Starfield was going to
be exclusive you know what he did
he said I want all that you want to try
to make Starfield exclusive cool I'm
taking zenderman and then and then
Bobby K came up to uh Phil and was like
if you don't get out and lay down I'm
gonna pull Activision content off you
know what Phil did he said I want that
Bobby that was that was a stick up Bobby
said 80 20. take it or leave it that's
right okay he took it all right
guess what let's go now there are people
that said this one's for you song
Atlas they just don't they don't care
about
Xbox they're never going to do anything
and then we find out just like Cinemax
just like Activision
oh okay Atlas you don't want to put
Persona on the platform
Target on your back
oh man it's on site
and if we look look at the final hit
Sega was on there as of April of 2021
yes right now I want to now that could
have been all going on then we get to
know then we get to
um November yes
when uh that's when we heard the uh
um the Activision talks first started
yes yes
so we're talking to Sega we're working
something out you know what else got
announced in November of 2021 it's
called partnership on super game yes so
they said Hold On
and they said by the way anything Atlas
does if Atlas sells a dime bag oh that's
the King of New York
announces a new game oh it's gonna be on
off stage
so they skipped us all this time but not
anymore
are you saying that that that Microsoft
gave them this uh strategic partnership
and told them hold the line for a moment
okay
I was gonna say imagine like them
getting uh flight tickets in the mail
and it's like why are we going to L.A
they have to come say oh you're going to
be on Microsoft station next week I'll
say what
so so the thing is right and I can't
find the Xbox
right so so now because what we want is
we we want Sega to be back in the
platform business again okay so that
Nintendo and Sony
uh can can can uh so say you can get
their revenge on them
how does this open the door for singing
back
fax business
this is like the ever boy Saga for real
this is like the books for real
they're gonna be running that show oh
this is the Leverage
yeah so you know how Bungie gets to put
all their games on all these platforms
if we're gonna be like nah you waiting
to be fair it could it be fair though in
that in the documents
I saw that yeah but the re the reason
for that and I I think it's smart even
though I don't like it right right now
Xbox is kind of non-existent in Japan
right we can all agree that yes so they
would have to go to Japanese regulators
and say good point one of your biggest
Publishers yup we're effectively gonna
pull them out country because nobody has
an Xbox
I think it would get shut down and they
have to do that until Xbox raises uh its
presence in the region or something you
don't like it but we got we got to deal
with it but that's fine I'm 100 behind
that right but yeah it's just like
second try to take over Xbox with the
inside like don't feed everybody a
couple years
a couple hold up a couple years they're
on stage King and they sitting up there
and they talking like we have done as
much as we can as the Xbox brand they
just burn the front it's like so now
we're mad now we're second 2.0
but he's trying to say Sega is the game
from G Unit yeah I eat infiltrated yeah
you're gonna start have the the dude
who's the charger
doing uh doing a lot of the stuff that
Phil does now he's like we we've come to
Xbox because we believe in their vision
and their Vision was our vision 10 15
years ago but but let me finish this up
for this video everybody got to go so
the thing is
um when they asked Sega about this
Sega didn't say outright no they said
not right now take it easy
right because they had to ask Sega
because Sega stock price on this news
was the highest it had been since 2007.
right so we know they got the
partnership for the super game we know
Atlas can't speak unless they talk to
Xbox
so we know that they can't stop talking
about how good Xbox is to them in Game
Pass and then they even said when they
got asked about this what they said
value Sega more than anything oh yeah
Sony values Sega yes and they said well
would you consider an operation they
said well easy right now not right
because you know what it's hot we know
not right now means they're in the
middle of something right now when
they're done with that it will no longer
be right now so we're gonna spin the
block we're gonna come back right and I
just want to point out to Mr casante you
know who wasn't in that let's Embrace a
group oh what are you doing that was
before but that was before Embrace
conspiracy theory oven actually that
they're hyped for Microsoft was in that
doctor Tomb Raider was online I actually
yeah I I have a different conspiracy
theory oh so we all have oh go for it
let's go yes we'll go ahead and let
people go because my conspiracy theories
actually solve solved you have to send
me a temple half profile I thought we
was about to get full attics
that I gotta get PK I gotta get PK Sega
uh uh Square was also on the list
feels anybody that was pulling games
from XBox they was on The Hit List wait
wait wait wait wait hold on this is ill
this is it hold on I'm sick I'm saying
fit matter of fact that booty is Agent
47.
you're the basic writer
your creative juices are flowing so you
telling me so the plan was okay they're
locking us out of exclusives right
they're taking these third-party
exclusive deals so we gonna Target the
ones that they have made exclusive and
own those companies that will be doing
everybody that's that's what that's not
what we do and that's what they did is
on the paper and the documents
this is the thing so we all listen we
can see right now from this trial that
Xbox has to play by a double standard
not only in the media we always knew
that but also you can see it in the
court that this whole five days was how
dare you make a
make have anything
how dare you not operate as a for-profit
organization we thought you would
absolutely
right so the all of the nice talk that
you see in in public is because they
already knew that they have to operate
by different rules as Sony but in the
background
it's world domination baby it was order
66. or I won't stop you right there
because here's the point of contingency
and then like after this I got it when
you respond I gotta get pkn all right
now here's the big point of contention
that I'm seeing right now in the streets
right a Christian I couldn't find
tinfoil my bad all right no doubt so the
court point of contention
oh I couldn't find aluminum so the party
contest Devil Boy is that people are
saying you know that there is a distinct
difference there's one thing to make a
third party exclusive but it's another
thing to own the company and then this
okay
but I just want to be fair to the other
side the other side is saying these are
Brute Force tactics right away they're
trying to be fair to the other side they
don't make no sense half the time we are
being balanced here
we gotta uh protect the consumer not
Sony
Bros those are boys
are like the FTC law
it wouldn't make sense yeah I'm sure
they got beefy checks over there
corporate [__] always respected the
gangster of Jim Wright where y'all were
making nicknames I didn't I didn't
engage none of that Hyperbole and I told
y'all son got influence in them in the
territory everybody was and then when
the blocking went down anyway this is
not about me moving back on them so the
question yeah the question is is it
wrong to be cheering on this aggressive
Brute Force nature of owning a company
versus doing it quote-unquote the
traditional way which is the third party
exclusive organically
and I'm just I have to ask everyone this
go ahead I got you I got you so here's
the thing
if it was just business then
don't cry now right so if if you want to
talk about business and these see here's
the thing the status quo
benefits the haves those who are in
power right now and that whole idea of
let's continue to do it the way you used
to do it because that happens to benefit
me we've see we've seen this in every
Walk of Life and in every argument of
that of everything nobody wants to upset
the apple cart and it's only the people
that benefit right now that tell you
this is the true god-given way of doing
things but but here's the thing even if
you want to take it from uh why are we
doing it this way why are we doing it
that way the people saying that would be
totally fine if Microsoft went the way
of Sega they won't say that out loud but
they'd be absolutely happy if that was
the case here listen to this right if
you do not